where did you sit your good seats I
think I yes I think I had really good
seats um you know it's for what I did
you know I just really introduced logic
that was like my only and I was
nominated to you know so you know maybe
I could have had better seats ya know
but honestly my seats were incredible I
was right there
you know like the stage kind of like you
know they had the part where they were
talking at and then they had like the
little loop that came out yeah yeah I
was the second row right in front of
that loop well did you we just watched
we're a little choked up I mean we just
watched a really touching tribute that
Madonna did with some reason I had a
picture of a reason Franklin in the back
and why she talked about everything she
was saying was I you know I mean it was
really fire I'm like okay this is like a
really cool interesting story but have
to do iterate read the Frank yeah that's
right well Aretha was a also a woman I
think that tighter then she's also a
lady I think that's how it tied in you
know that was I mean them man
I don't know that that's a good one that
was like that is true she's ladies
well she said at one point she tried to
sing a wreath in an audition and they
didn't think she could but then luckily
Madonna rose above it and that was
important in the Aretha tribute to hear
how Madonna rose above it yeah dude I
felt the same way and you know I I
didn't watch that in person but when I
went back to my hotel room and was
watching it again I was like what this
happened what I like finally finally
there's somebody on stage at the VMAs
they're gonna let you know the struggles
of being a pretty skinny white woman it
was I'm not lighted it was weird do
people hate it I don't know if other
people hated it I personally I didn't
necessarily hate it cuz like I said like
I think listening to Madonna give a
really based story is dope
like I'm here for that just I didn't I'm
not here for that mixed with you know we
need to pay tribute to Aretha Franklin
right yeah so weird I think we need to
pay tribute to read the Franklin we
should pay tribute to Aretha Franklin
right in a very like transparent to the
point kind of way yeah I don't think you
should play with that duty and not that
Madonna did you know I think
is based based you know definition of
based does that mean a self-centered ass
you know you're just kind of out there
like no right which I think Madonna
kinda is so maybe that's why she did
that but definitely I didn't look at
that as though are you I was like this
could be better right now are you at a
point doing good Madonna but this could
be that this cute yeah this could be
different and like you said if Madonna
is up there doing a speech about herself
that's fine like you guys have a tribute
yeah but it's like come on this is a
wreath or franklin's moment right here
you should be doing a better job than
telling us about this weird ass [ __ ]
about you there's a boring audition
story I hate that I audition and bomb
for other things it was terrible I've
never made a [ __ ] as an 8-minute
story about you know I'm not gonna
tribute Richard Pryor by telling us
story about me bombing in 1992 yeah so I
stole a couple of his jokes and finally
you got some fun and then all right one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]